you ready for this
i've been ready for this my whole life
all right i was thinking of doing a
kerouac style road trip
across the united states you know after
this whole
covid thing lifts you ever take a trip
like that i've done a handful of
long distance driving trips um up and
down the east coast but also
from the west coast back to the east
coast and then returning to california
so i've definitely done my fair share of
driving
in this country do you have the longing
for the great american road trip
i think there are so many things that
i've been lucky enough to see in the
world
that i now at this point in my life
realize there are tons of things that i
need to see here
in this country and a road trip could
potentially be the best way
to see them i think to do it effectively
you need an amount of time
where you can be as leisurely as
possible there's no deadline and there's
no
i've got to make it from chicago to st
louis by sundown to get to this place at
this time
i think you really need to be able to
take your time and uh
and kind of like let the road take you
where you need to go
it feels like you need a mission though
ultimately like there's a reason you
need to be in san francisco that's like
the kerala
thing you have to meet somebody
somewhere kind of loosely in a few weeks
and then it's the as you
struggle on towards that mission you
meet weird characters that get in your
way but ultimately sort of
create an experience i think having a
loose deadline is good
but that's a beginning and an end point
and what i mean is
i don't want to have to be all right
we're leaving say boston
on sunday night let's get to new york by
monday morning and then from new york
we're going to go to philly and we've
got to be in philly at 4.
a vague beginning and end is fine but i
think having very strict guidelines
in between will rob you of certain
experiences along the way
if you have a time frame to get from
philly to indianapolis
and some awesome [ __ ] starts to happen
in philly do you really want to have to
cut it short because you got to be in
indianapolis by sunup
why do you have to be anywhere by any
time for any reason really
plans change plans change all the time
exactly but if we're talking about
um having a mission or the type of road
trip
i just think it would be best to have it
as loose and
uh flexible as possible i don't know you
gotta make
hard deadlines and then break them
totally change the plans disappoint
people break promises
that's the way of life somebody's
waiting for you in st louis
and all of a sudden you you fell in love
with a biker
in new york i don't know i don't know
what you're up to i can appreciate that
um but on a trip like that i feel like
a trip with deadlines is for a different
point in your life
and at this point in my life i don't
want any of the deadlines because
it's not about meeting someone and
disappointing them in st
louis it's about me not disappointing
myself
you want to have you want to have enough
time in what you're doing to make sure
that
you get the full breadth of every
experience that you encounter
how would you fully experience a place
how would you you know i i don't think
i've actually fully experienced boston
like how if you were showing up to
a city for a week on this road trip what
would you do
so i'm going to answer that in two parts
a few years ago i had an opportunity to
move out of boston
and the thing that kept me here no
question about it was the fact that i
felt like i had a
um a contract with my students
and i did not i felt like a great many
of them took a leap of faith
uh by joining my gym and like you know
asking me to teach them what i know and
when i had an opportunity to leave
boston i thought of those people
and i thought i want to fulfill my
obligation to them so because i made a
decision to stay here i then that summer
made a decision to endear myself to the
city of boston and i tried to find lots
and lots of different things to do
i can tell you that the coolest thing
that i found to do in this city is
um the mfa where they have like on
friday nights they'll have like
different exhibits and stuff
and they'll have like little beer carts
and food tents and you can go
do a painting class off in the on the
side
very cool night of things to do but in
general
whenever i'm in a new city i try not to
pay attention to google and i try not to
do anything
that i find on a travel site the best
thing to do
is to walk out of your hotel or wherever
it is you're staying and find the most
normal looking bar have a drink and talk
to a bartender
so the people the people the people and
then you can experience
that town the way that they experience
it even in a city where there are tons
of tourist attractions
locals probably visit the same tourist
attractions when they have visitors come
from out of town
but you want to see how they view those
places and how they visit them
and you want to go to eat where they're
going to eat like
you know you're gonna i'd for the most
part
the north end is not a place where i
would take someone and say
hey this is boston's the pinnacle of
boston
dining because it's very touristy there
are a handful of really good restaurants
there
but i want to know where the where the i
want to go to bogey's place i want to
know like the the down low spots where
the hell is bogey's place it's like a
little steak house in the back of jm
curly's
exactly it's like a shitty bar it's just
a bar with like bar food
but i think they're like um boston
it is in boston yeah it's not south
boston no it's in um
[Music]
it's in the downtown area like um
i don't know what the neighborhoods are
called here honestly because they call
they they have an area called downtown
boston and i don't even know what the
hell that means
i think he's near the financial district
where's southie because i've heard about
the southie
southeast south boston but is there is
there a difference between south boston
and southie
no it's the same thing no but like you
know the mythical south
i think the mythical southie is uh
something that's
long gone now and the term now actually
is sobo oh no yeah it's
it's changed what who who took over what
what's the
you know the goodwill hunting
personality that's southie isn't it
strong accent those badass dudes
i came here right at the end of like
what was south boston so when i got
and my gym is in south boston the
neighborhood was just starting to change
so i think
as gentrification happened and they
started building more luxury
condominiums they were buying all these
old businesses out all the mom and pop
businesses and i think
that kind of changed the the makeup of
the community and it wasn't only because
there was an
influx of new young people uh with
disposable income
is because there's an exodus of the the
older people who kind of grew up and
raised their families there because they
were being offered
humongous sums of money for their homes
that they had bought like in the late
70s and early 80s
so that they could develop those areas
so you have a combination of the influx
of new people
in the exodus of the old and now you
just got this totally new neighborhood
in its place what do you love about
boston
is there a love still for boston
you certainly have the love of the thing
that's gone as well
yeah i think i don't want to pinpoint
pin this on boston because it's
happening in all great cities
as these areas become gentrified what's
happening is the personality and the
character of the neighborhood is just
being run out
and i have nothing against people coming
in and making money and things like that
but
when you do it at the expense of the
culture the character and the
personality of the neighborhood
i mean you're kind of standing on the
shoulders of giants these are the people
that came here and built these areas up
and it happens here in in boston it
happens in all over new york
uh happens on the west coast so what i
love about boston is not nearly as
romantic as what it might have been 15
years ago and what i used to love about
new york
what i love about boston is that um
it's walkable um the food scene is on
is on the rise here um but i think
you're
you're hard-pressed to find the charm
that
people think of when they think of old
boston and old new england city
see i see it differently people
sometimes criticize like mit
like for the thing that it is now but i
think it is
always like that i
tend to prefer to carry the flame
of the his of the greatness the greatest
moments of his history
and like sort of enjoy that the echoes
of that in the halls of mit in the same
way in boston you think about the
history
and that history lives on in the few
individuals
like you can't just look around where
boston is now and be like what has
boston become
i think it was always carried by a
minority of individuals
i i think we kind of look back in
history and think like
times were greater in a certain kind of
dimension back then but
that's because we remember uh this is a
ridiculous
non-data-driven assertion of mine is we
remember just the
the the brightest stars of that history
and so we romanticize it but i think if
you look around now
those special people are still living in
boston for which boston will be
remembered as a great city
in like 50 years i think you're probably
right but isn't there some sort of
theory about
the point that there's like a certain
age in your life where things resonate
differently to you like i think they've
done studies where
most people stop searching for new music
after age 19.
most dads you see like wearing super old
clothes like the
that's the style of the time period of
the last great part of their life
so like there's an evolution in in
people and it could also be the memories
of where they live
when i was 17 of course my neighborhood
was the best then because i was having
the most fun
and we always kind of look at things
through uh that that tint
i think and you're right and i don't
think there's anything wrong with the
way
cities are evolving now it's just not um
i i i preferred a time of like a mom and
pop store
not a fabricated like uh gastro pub that
could just be
like on a four lane super highway and
you're on your way out of epcot center
and it's it's actually owned by like
some conglomerate but there's still the
special places like i
this takes us back to the road trip is
um
maybe i tend to romanticize the
experiences of like the diners in the
middle of nowhere
uh what would you say makes for like
it feels like life is made up of these
experiences
that are that maybe on paper seem
mundane
but are actually somehow give you a
chance
to pause and reflect on life with like a
certain kind of
people whether like really close friends
or complete strangers
maybe alcohol is involved in the middle
of nowhere it seems like road trip
facilitates that if you allow it to like
what do you think
makes for those kind of experience have
you had any
i think in the context of a road trip i
think it's like hyper localization
and i think it is um those
those experiences along the way
with people and the people that you're
with will color the experiences
differently depending on
the person the road trip you took was uh
with somebody else alone so
i've driven up and down the east coast
several times when i
drove from l.a to new york uh my friend
was
uh on the run from the cops yeah so
we were trying to get traffic tickets
yeah
yeah allegedly we're trying to get out
of la because um
he was going to have to go away for a
little while yeah so we drove from la
and we just you know we were young kids
we had no idea what we were doing
and we drove east and then you know we
had an unbelievable trip
mostly because we didn't really have a
destination we didn't really have a time
frame thank goodness
uh because he got arrested again in
pennsylvania so we got kind of stuck
there
and then um you know and then we we
drove back to la when he got
out in pennsylvania um
but all the stops along the way
were kind of like weird things like you
have no money right so you're finding
that like
a little diamond in the rough place to
eat the diner you talk about like that
place
i i once was in where was i i think i
was in buenos aires and the guy that i
was with
he said i know this quaint little spot
around the corner
and i was young i was like 25 and i
thought the coolest thing in the world
would be
to be such a citizen of the world that
you know these quaint little spots
around the corner in like all these
great cities like
i know where to get this great chicken
sandwich in argentina i know where to
get this great meal in costa rica
i know where to get this super local
like um egg in
another country i always thought that
that was really cool the ability to do
that
anywhere in the world did you get closer
with that guy
went out through the trip i found that
like so i took i took a trip across the
united states with a
with a guy friend of mine we had
different goals i was searching for a
meaning in life and he was searching for
um
what's the politically correct way of
phrasing it but just uh
basically trying to sleep with every
kind of woman that this world has to
offer what's the difference between
those two things
well i guess the different kinds of
meanings
i i mean i just i i still think that you
can't find meaning
between a woman's legs i suppose uh that
maybe they tried all of them
but there was a tension there we grew
closer with those experiences but we've
gotten in fights
you know there was a lot of like literal
almost fights
and then we were close and there was
like silences but then we were like
brothers and this whole weird
journey of friendship that we went on i
think any time you
spend that much time in uh like a small
space with another person
you're gonna have the the different
parts of the relationship will manifest
themselves you'll have the periods of
closeness
you'll have the periods of vulnerability
where it's like maybe you're driving
through denver and it's three in the
morning and you talk about something you
might not have otherwise talked about
you'll have the periods where you don't
want to see that [ __ ] ever again
right he didn't and depending could be
because of anything
yeah um but the guy that i drove twice
with
we are still we're still in contact
we're still buddies
we we have very different goals also
um but at that point in our lives we
were not we never even contemplated the
meaning of life
we were about probably more to the point
of the friend that you drove with
we were more about racking up
experiences whatever they were right
i want to be able to retell this hmm
stories
yeah i want to be able to retell this
and it's got to sound cool
like i don't want to retell a story
about yeah and then we drove through
alabama and they've got a lovely library
and i checked out this book
and you know i'm not interested in
retelling that do you remember any um
oh this is a kids show do you remember
any stories that the kids would enjoy
from those times that were profound in
some kind of way
there were some impactful moments on the
beginning of our road trip where we had
no money and as a couple of kids who
knew nothing
we literally had to we stopped in vegas
and we went to circus circus
at the time they had three dollar
blackjack and we had like 12 bucks and
my buddy was a kind of a degenerate
gambler so he knew what was up but i was
just like kind of stuffing chips in my
pockets making sure we could pay for the
gas
um and just being at the point which is
like a starting line
and like we drove from la to vegas which
is only about four hours
and being at the starting line and
realizing like we may not even like
get off the starting line here and if we
don't what are we doing we're gonna be
two guys stuck in vegas with no money we
can't go west because you're gonna get
pinched
with no money to go east what the hell
are we going to do we're going to wind
up in vegas
um so you know that that was kind of a
profound thing where you just
it's a turning it potentially could have
been a turning point in our lives
had we not made enough money to to
continue going east
that's the beautiful thing about road
trips when you're broke it's like
in retrospect everything turned out fine
but
you're facing the complete darkness the
uncertainty of the possibilities laid
before you and like
i don't know if you were confident at
that time but like
i was really full of self-doubt
like just like all i could see is all
the trajectories where you just screw up
your life like what am i doing with my
life i'm
a failure like all these dreams i've had
i've never realized i'm a complete piece
of [ __ ]
all those kinds of i had no concept of
consequence
i i like i was i probably had
toxoplasmosis
i had literally no concept of
consequence
immediate gratification was all i cared
about oh so existentialist
yeah it did not it did not even enter my
mind
at in my like early 20s that anything
that i was doing at that point
could reverberate for the rest of my
life i think part of me didn't even
think i'd make it this far
and so i was not interested in like the
long play i remember thinking like why
should i be
acting now in a way that might impact a
point in my life i never reach
you